congratulations on this
thank you brother your uh your director
said that this was that morbius was kind
of like the kurt cobain of the mcu and
that the performance was a little bit
spooky but what was your take on him
what did you how would you describe him
complicated
how's it what are those complications
that drew you to the character i mean i
love that this is a guy when we meet dr
michael morbius he's uh he's sick and
frail and fragile he's he's searching
for a cure for a really rare disease
that he has and and others like him
uh
uh
and then he becomes strong and powerful
and ultimately monstrous so i like that
there were really three performances in
one and there's quite a big
transformation there
i went from time
to feeling more alive than ever
increased strength and speed
the ability to use echolocation
the other thing that excited me is this
is the very first time this character
has been on the big screen and it was
you know quite an honor to be asked to
do it yeah it must feel good to put your
mark on something yeah but let me ask
you a question brother are those
shutters or is that a bookshelf because
i'm really confused those i'll give you
the little bts tour this is my garage
those are guacamole those are uh like
they're kind of like room dividers
but are these is that real that's a
painting no or is it real they're real
oh my god um do you understand that
looks like i thought that was like a
zoom background no no no even now that
you touched it it looks like it's
animated this is my dirty garage except
for this right here so that's like a a
shoji screen but made out of like
shutters yes exactly yeah yeah yeah
holy i got it guacamole
in my mind
what was the most fun thing about
you know having your own solo marvel
film
everything i mean it it you know i in
some ways uh
you know i've never done anything like
this before i've never starred in a big
movie like this before
i generally you know and doing different
sorts of films and
you know i just uh jumped at the
opportunity it was uh it's a really
special thing to be proud of and you
know i love the fact that this is you
know
this is a big marvel uh film with this
you know classic marvel character but it
also takes a walk on the darker side of
the universe it it kind of touches on
horror it gets a bit scary at times
and um yeah it was new territory for me
and i absolutely loved it
is worse than the disease
what's the most stressful part of
it i'll be talking to you
as i
no um the most stressful part was uh
um the most stressful part was probably
the physical um challenges you know i
mean
the the three very different variations
of the same character here
and each was fully realized and nuanced
and complicated
you know that battle between good and
evil and um
but the physical last but the physical
challenges of the role probably the most
uh
the the
the hardest i should have died years ago
why am i still here if not to fix this
is that something that when you when
you're finding a role the physical
challenge and this is going to sound
like a horrible pun but i look forward
to sinking your teeth into the most
yeah that's a horrible pun
as it hit my brain i was like you won
there's no other way to do this though
you won congratulations you won
congratulations
i mean today you're going down in
history as
you wanted and by the way let me tell
you something as we go around the world
doing these interviews with the junkets
we we've had some doozies i'm sure i'm
sure i didn't even write that one i
didn't think of it you didn't have to
write it right it's called inspiration
it was right there oh the inspiration
and you know creative prowess you did it
thank you thank you thank you
trump loyal in the background and a
panda
match i read your variety interview and
the the quote that's getting the most
pick up is if it wasn't for marvel films
i don't know that movie theaters would
exist um is there any additional context
that you can add to that why do you
think that sparked such a huge
conversation it did it i have no idea
i'd like to say i pretty much just bury
my head in the sand and say a lot of
stupid [ __ ] and then let everybody go
have fun with it but
i i i would i would say it again i mean
are people upset with it do they agree
with it what were they confused about it
i think probably confused i think
probably confused i'm not confused i
think i and i understand what's pretty
simple let me explain it to the the
people that are a little slow out there
if you look at the box office and what
people are buying tickets for
i worked at a movie theater as a kid
okay
and and i'm talking about what's
actually generating the revenue to keep
the buildings open and the people
employed and the
the ecosystem thriving
if you look at the past whatever years
that these films have been around i
would say that they're probably
the biggest uh
generators of revenue these films so in
a sense you should be think we should be
thankful especially people that are a
big fan of
cinema that are a big fan of theaters
we should be thankful that these films
even exist
because they help support the ecosystem
so that other films
that are adult dramas like kausaguchi
have theaters that they can actually be
in
that's my point maybe that was lost in
translation but it seems it's pretty
it's pretty hard to argue with that take
now now conversely take those take all
the marvel and dc movies
out right take him out
what what what what what what are you
going to do those those theaters a lot
of those theaters wouldn't even exist
yeah no i'm a person that's made a
career out of doing mostly independent
film and art movies yeah
people like to get upset about like you
know
a sunset
these days so uh they can kiss my ass
but
they uh but but i don't understand you
know for me i was thinking that that's
actually a nice thing that these films
are are able to
support
you know the the ecosystem and that we
still have theaters i mean i think it's
a sacred thing
um
uh cinema and it's a beautiful thing it
changed my life you know i i grew up i
would just show up at the independent
theater and just see whatever was
playing you know i'm a kid that went i
went to film school
and in some ways you know being an actor
and having gone to film school and being
part of this business for some for so
long i'm i mean i have to say i'm kind
of an authority on the subject
so you take it take it for what
how you will but that that's my opinion
[Laughter]
jared leto passed spoken man thank you i
appreciate that who knew that who knew
that the world would be rocked about a
statement about you know movies it
seemed pretty obvious they're called
their they were called tentpole movies
for so long because it kept everything
it kept the lights there you go my
friend and then you can you know there
you go there it is
[Music]
you